you bought Jeff a toilet like a fancy
toilet uh-huh
why did you buy him a fancy toilet why
not
okay then where's my fancy toilet I
think that takes the question coming
right up yeah it was like when you went
over for dinner yeah I was dead of a
bottle of wine you brought a toilet the
toilet when you said where's my fancy
toilet I was about to say you have a
show yeah but no that was a direct
gyllenhaal hit congratulation but I
would say that you know this toilet is
extraordinary it is it is it is it is a
bead bidet a bidet
it is a Boucher you're so excited about
this toilet talk about is a bidet seat
[Laughter]
[Applause]
weight automatically rises when you move
towards it yes it has it's it's it's
heated yeah so that when you sit on it
right your butt is warm right right
there's so many amazing things about
this toilet now wait a minute you know
first of all I think I've encountered
these toilets every now and oh I have
you well I have because every now and
then I like in New York when I go to the
alright on a walk run I yeah every now
and then I see one crossed my path
the creepiest thing about those toilets
if you're staying in a nice hotel you
walk into the bathroom and anytime it
senses you there the top list and it's
almost like it's like you want to go now
I'm always like no I'm coming in too and
I sometimes talk to them like I'm just
here to brush my teeth I'm always like
can I go again I have a friend who has
like three of them and and I was staying
in his guest room and as I walk towards
and in the middle of the night I come
back and I'm walking towards the room
and all the bathroom doors are open and
as I walk it's like a symphony of
toilets just okay it's like finding Nemo
yeah that's a weird version of Finding
Nemo you and I should both produce it
somehow equated seagulls to boys yes
which is I liked it right
you